jean-marc votre avis les gens on va sur
france inter on a consacré une grande
enquête à lafarge là qu'on a diffusé il
ya un mois lafarge en syrie
particulièrement sur cette cimenterie
qui est situé dans la zone de jaca donc
on est vraiment en planant l'intérieur
de neige en plaine dans est il seulement
envisageable
un seul instant aucune entreprise de la
taille de lafarge s'est leader mondial
du secteur puissent maintenir cette
cimenterie dans des conditions dont on
ne sache au niveau des pouvoirs publics
que il ya quelque chose qui relève du
bakchich j'allais dire pas seulement
avec le groupe etat islamique mais un
peu avec tout le monde
enfin posé la question à mon avis c'est
y répondre et si on va et mais on peut
inverser le sujet pardon d'être
totalement cynique je vais être
totalement cynique je préviens d'avancé
le autant que je puisse le savoir le
responsable de la sécurité du groupe
lafarge est quelqu'un qui connaît très
bien les services français c'est
quelqu'un qui a travaillé dans les
forces spéciales qui a travaillé dans
les commandos donc on est en droit de
penser que l'univers des services ne
vais pas un univers étrange et on peut
donc inversé de sujets c'est une
hypothèse mais elle n'est quand même pas
totalement farfelu c'est que c'était
aussi un moyen d'avoir une implantation
sur zone pour les services pour
surveiller les activités des groupes
terroristes
là vous renverser la perspective a alors
cessé complètement cynique parce que le
le revers si je puis dire de cette
hypothèse c'est que malgré tout vous
financier dé facto le terrorisme avec
les conséquences que l'on sait donc
c'est extrêmement troublant mais c'est
quand même pas une hypothèse totalement
absurde vu ce qu'est la farge c'est pas
une pme dans une loi qui fait son truc
parents souvent